hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ihr seht bereits im Titel
eingeblendet was ich mal wieder für eine
dumme Aktion gebracht habe
denn ich habe bei einer Fundsachen
auktionswebsite für 157 € einen verloren
gegangenen Koffer gekauft
[Applaus]
157 € kelly missesvlog hat das Ganze vor
2 Jahren schon getestet und ich hoffe
dass ich in meinem Koffer auch ein paar
Schätzchen drin habe
ich bezweifle das aber fangen wir
allerdings erstmal mit dem Design des
Koffers an das ist ein Check-In Koffer
ziemlich gebraucht hat hier oben
irgendwie Kreppband dran kleben
ich glaube der wird so ca 2,50 sein
allerdings machen wir den Koffer jetzt
einfach mal zusammen auf und schauen was
ich
oh wow
hier sind einfach noch nasse Badesachen
drin aber nur so teuer weil die andere
Person der der Koffer gehört hat mit
geboten hat und ich habe die Person
entschuldigung ich würde allerdings
sagen wir fangen auch direkt mit dieser
Plastiktüte an denn da drin
boah
Hardcore ekelhaft fällt mir gerade auch
in dieser Plastiktüte befand sich ein
top
das sind wahrscheinlich keine
Schwimmsachen sondern Schmutzwäsche
dieses T-Shirt haben wir da auch noch
drin das ist ein
[Musik]
ja die waren auf jeden Fall irgendwo am
Meer im Urlaub also wenn er so so ein
Anker drauf ist und so noch ein Tanktop
oder das ist ein Knast Outfit
Bierglas vielleicht waren die auf
Mallorca oder so kann ja sein dass es
irgendwie ein Bierkönig Glas ist oder
sowas die mitgenommen aber sehr sehr
wild und da drin
kann das überhaupt noch nass sein diese
Koffer gehen oder drei Monaten oder so
glaube ich in die Option oder das ist
Kälte
ich weiß nicht oh nee stimmt auch Mann
es wäre richtig krass wenn er zum Laptop
drin liegen würde oder so
aber ich glaube niemand ist so blöd und
Laptop in seinen Koffer wir haben ja auf
jeden Fall auch noch ein Buch drin was
auch erst zur Hälfte gelesen wurde also
die Person der das gehört hat er hat das
auf jeden Fall nichts ab das pokerbuch
mein Jahr als Zocker
die Person vielleicht Notiz noch dran
gemacht
was diese Zeichen sagt ja auch schon oft
einiges aus um
das ist ein polnisches
das ist ein polnisches Ticket
als Lesezeichen
das heißt der Koffer ist wahrscheinlich
von irgendwelchen Polen die Urlaub
gemacht haben
ich male mir gerade so eine Person vor
der der Koffer gehört haben könnte auf
jeden Fall befindet sich dort drin auch
noch ein Handtuch von
IB Ibiza Ibiza oh mein Gott okay die
Leute waren auf Ibiza nicht auf Mallorca
hier sehen war Ibiza Handtuch das ist
auf jeden Fall sehr wichtig sogar
behalten tatsächlich ich bin im
September sogar noch ein Kartenspiel
drin auch sehr sehr cool werde ich
definitiv auch behalten kostet 2 €, aber
das ist nicht so dass es in Deutschland
irgendwie so
2 € gekostet hätte weil dann wäre das
Safe irgendwie noch so ein Barcode drauf
gewesen oder so sondern Urlaub gekauft
ist auch
vollständig mehr oder weniger und das
sieht auch benutzt das ist jetzt nicht
in irgendeinereien Folge also wir haben
auf jeden Fall auch Karten gespielt auf
Ibiza dann haben wir hier frische Schuhe
mit am Start einfach
Air Max oder so heißen ja glaube ich ich
weiß jetzt nicht sind das Frauen oder
Männer Schuhe keine Ahnung ich tendiere
eher zu frauenschulen wegen dem
violetten Design und so aber Schuhgröße
ja Schuhgröße nach zu unter seiner so
42er oder so dann haben wir auf jeden
Fall noch Sockenpaare drin die werde ich
jetzt nicht aus
ach du heilige Scheiße sind einfach Lidl
Socken
ich glaube das waren richtige
suff-urlauber die sich auf Ibiza dachten
ey guck mal wir brauchen Kartenspiel zum
Saufen Lidl Socken und irgendwie sowas
und
dann aber trotzdem vorher so ein Buch
mitgenommen von wegen Poker ja wenn man
verkatert am Pool dann liegt dann haben
wir hier noch ein Nike Waffel Shirt
ein Nike just do it Shirt
und natürlich weil es nicht fehlen darf
auf Ibiza ein Palmen Hemd mit Bier
also ich stelle mir gerade wirklich so
eine Person vor sondern Deutsch
polnischen der sich denkt mit seinen
Jungs kommen ich machen Ibiza Urlaub ich
nehme auch ein paar Sportsachen mit weil
man hat vorher gesagt man geht
vielleicht noch eine Runde joggen hat
man schlussendlich aber kein mal gemacht
dann haben wir hier drin auch noch eine
kulturbox von molten Brown London eine
lederbox und darin befindet sich ein
Rasierer
für den habe ich keinen Bedarf daran
befindet sich noch eine Dior Parfum was
aber leer ist es riecht allerdings
ziemlich abstoßend in der kulturbox
befindet sich ebenfalls noch ein paar
Ohropax okay also wir kommen der Sache
wirklich näher und ich denke es werden
wirklich Partyurlauber gewesen sein wir
haben allerdings noch eine zweite
kulturbox von der gleichen Marke
allerdings ein bisschen kleiner worin
sich wahrscheinlich Zahnbürsten zu
befinden ja genau wir haben hier eine
Zahnbürste drin oh nein
das ist wirklich so eine Mini Zahnbürste
ich habe letztens in dem Video mir so
Sachen von dm gekauft die ich ein
bisschen unnötig fand
diese Person besaß so eine Zahnbürste
Kondome wurden also auch eingepackt und
dann würde ich sagen mittlerweile zu
98,4 % bei einem klassischen Malle Ibiza
Urlaub Menschen
in Schnorchel ich dachte es wäre eine
Bierbaum oder so Taucherbrille und
Schnorchel darf auf jeden Fall auch
nicht fehlen wenn man auf Ibiza ist es
ist irgendwie so es passt alles nicht so
ganz zusammen wenn du mit deinen Jungs
dahin fährst dann passt wieder das Bier
Glas und die Kondome aber du nimmst doch
dann nicht ein Schnorchel mit das machst
du wenn ein Familienmensch bist und
warum hat die Person ein polnisches
Parkticket
viele Dinge verstehe ich nicht sogar
dann haben wir auch noch einen Hoodie
drin von der Marke
oder finde ich auch Schwachsinn so hart
zip was ist das sind nichts Ganzes Mann
der macht das also wirklich kein Mensch
macht so das war allerdings erst die
eine Seite des Koffers der mir noch eine
zweite
oh nein in der zweiten Seite des Koffers
befindet sich eine Pringles Dose
welcher mensch
da sind auch noch Chips drin
sorry wenn ich jetzt eine E-Mail Mystery
Box mal wieder gekauft hat und da hat
jemand das reingetan okay in Ordnung der
musste das Paket für kommen meistens
gescannt aber bei einem Koffer
welcher Typ denkt sich ich denke mal das
war ein Typ wegen Kondom welcher Typ
denkt sich ey ich reiße jetzt ab von
Ibiza Male keine Ahnung was ich stopfe
da noch eine Packung Pringles rein
wer nervt jetzt schon wieder neben der
Packung Pringles haben wir dort auf
jeden Fall auch noch einen äh was ist
das
eine sehr gute Chini Jacke
[Gelächter]
wenn irgendwie hat die Wasser irgendwie
ach Gottchen ist noch eine Hose mit
dabei oder was
wir haben eine sehr gute tatini
kompletten
komplett Anzug und ach
selbstverständlich boah die will ich gar
nicht anfassen ne
was ist ekelhaft oh nee das sind da da
noch ein bisschen drin
die hebe ich jetzt mal nicht an aber
schaut
boah ey wirklich wenn dir der Koffer
gehört bitte schreibt mir bei Instagram
Laser Luca ich lese in letzter Zeit sehr
häufig meine DMS bitte schreib mir da
ey Bro hole den verdammten Koffer ab des
Weiteren haben wir hier drin auch noch
eine Spanien nee Deutsch nee was hä was
ist das ach das ist ein Umhang
deutscher Fußball Bund Umhang also
[Applaus]
das heißt die Person ist safe deutscher
als Polo holst du den jemals einen DFB
Umhang nicht mal die Deutschen sind Fans
vom DFB oder frei mich trotzdem diese
polnische Parkticket Karte da
reingekommen ist auf jeden Fall noch
eine Badehose hier mit am Start auch ein
ziemlich beschissenes Design mit
Papageien drauf und zu guter letzt noch
eine New Yorker Tüte die tatsächlich ein
Nein
der Luftmatratze beinhaltet
also klar okay wir fassen mal zusammen
vielleicht hat die Person auch noch
einen zweiten Koffer dabei gehabt den
die Person mitgenommen hat wenn er zwei
Koffer hatte denkt er sich auch
vielleicht nicht im ersten Moment ich
habe einen anderen Koffer vergessen
nur Krams drin der wirklich nicht mal an
der 157 Euro kostet dass ich dafür
ausgegeben habe aber
trotzdem Bro wieso nimmst du eine
Luftmatratze mit
ja gut wenn du die kaufst vielleicht im
Urlaub dann ist chillig dann denkt man
sich so wenn das Ding 50 € gekostet aber
ich habe richtig häufig schon diese
Sachen gemacht wo ich mir so Mystery
Boxen gekauft habe von Amazon von von
keine Ahnung von verschiedenen
eigentlich nur von Amazon von Ebay von
Ebay Entschuldigung Amazon habe ich auch
schon gemacht auf jeden Fall dass ich
eigentlich nahezu immer gescammt wurde
also hier ist halt das ist halt real so
ein Koffer von irgendwem aber
wer packt denn so dumm seine Sachen
[Musik]